bien Monsieur le Directeur Général mes
chers collègues nous entendons ce matin
monsieur Stanislas Bouron candidat
proposé par le Président de la
République pour occuper la fonction de
directeur général de l'Agence nationale
de la cohésion des territoires la NCT en
application du cinquième alinéa de
l'article 13 de la Constitution dont
vous trouverez les éléments
biographiques sur notre application
dimetteur comme vous le savez cette
nomination ne peut intervenir qu'après
l'audition de la personne pressentie
devant les commissions compétentes de
l'Assemblée nationale et du Sénat
audition qui doivent être suivies d'un
vote je rappelle que cette nomination ne
pourra intervenir si l'addition des
votes négatifs de chaque commission
représentée au moins les trois cinquième
des suffrages exprimés dans les deux
commissions
cette audition est publique elle est
ouverte à la presse et retransmis sur le
site du Sénat à l'issue nous procéderons
au vote à bulletin secret je rappelle
qu'il ne peut y avoir de délégation de
vote et que le dépouillement doit être
effectué simultanément avec l'Assemblée
nationale
à ces dégages je précise que l'Assemblée
nationale procédera à votre audition le
16 novembre matin je rappelle aussi que
si vous êtes devant nous aujourd'hui
c'est parce que le Sénat a souhaité
prévoir l'audition du directeur général
pressenti de la NCT par les commissions
permanentes compétentes du Parlement
dans le cas d'une proposition de loi
organique qui avait été adoptée
conjointement à la proposition de loi
ordinaire portant création de la NCT il
s'agit de la loi organique du 26 juillet
2019 relative à l'anonyme à la
nomination directeur général de la NCT
je vais sans attendre passer la parole
de votre rapporteur que je salue qui va
conduire votre audition vous pouvez
ensuite nous présenter votre candidature
et nous faire part de vos motivations
avant de répondre au première question
du rapporteur puis mes collections vous
interrogeront à leur tour pour une
séquence de questions réponses je vous
remercie la parole est en rapport
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur général mais chers collègues
je me réjouis de cette audition et je
suis heureux de pouvoir exprimer les
premières interrogations de notre
commission interrogation sur
l'adéquation de votre profil avec les
fonctions auxquelles le président de la
République vous destine comme directeur
général de l'anct interrogation
également sur votre projet pour cette
agence dont l'émission comme vient de le
rappeler le président lonjo concerne
directement les compétences de notre
commission
une première remarque liminaire lors de
son audition en 2019 le directeur
général actuel de la NCT Yves Le Breton
indiqué l'agence ne trouvera sa place
que si une harmonie s'instore fondée sur
une convergence de vision entre le
conseil d'administration son président
est le directeur général or le président
de la République nous demande de valider
votre nomination comme directeur général
de la NCT alors même que le ou la
présidente du conseil d'administration
de la NCT qui doit être choisie dans le
collège des élus locaux ne l'a pas
encore été je parle bien sûr du
remplacement de Madame la Ministre
Caroline Cayeux
faut-il voir dans la présence de nez au
choix du directeur général sur le choix
de la présidence du CA la volonté de
l'État de voir le directeur général
déterminer les conditions de cette
harmonie et c'est à dire que le
président du conseil d'administration
qui sera un élu local devra s'adapter à
votre vision ou qu'il sera choisi en
fonction de sa convergence de vue avec
la vôtre nous serons extrêmement heureux
de vous entendre sur ce point j'entre
maintenant dans le détail des questions
que je souhaitais vous poser
permettez-moi d'abord de revenir sur
votre parcours
il s'agit Monsieur le Directeur général
d'un parcours assez remarquable de
serviteurs de l'État et je ne dis pas
cela uniquement car il a débuté sur les
bancs du prestigieux Institut d'études
politiques de Grenoble qui a tant donné
à la France après l'École nationale
d'administration vous avez été affectés
au ministère de l'Intérieur au sein
duquel vous avez occupé de nombreux
postes principalement en administration
centrale comme adjoint puis chef du
bureau des élections et des études
politiques puis comme sous-directeur des
compétences et des institutions locales
puis comme chef de service adjoint au
directeur général des collectivités
locales et enfin comme directeur des
ressources humaines avant de devenir
directeur général des collectivités
locales des GSL en juillet 2019
votre parcours de haut fonctionnaire
témoigne donc de vos compétences
toutefois dans ce parcours je ne vois
qu'une seule expérience dans les
services déconcentrés de l'État comme
sous préfet chargé de mission pour la
politique de la ville entre 2002 et 2005
auprès du préfet de région
Nord-Pas-de-Calais vous n'êtes pas sans
savoir que le Sénat porte une attention
toute particulière à la ruralité aux
difficultés que rencontrent les
habitants des zones rurales et aux
opportunités que présente ces
territoires ruraux pour la transition
énergétique pour le développement
économique en général et pour le lien
social au plus proche de nos concitoyens
mes deux premières questions seront donc
les suivantes et je vous les poserai de
manière franche et directe votre
prédécesseur de son audition avait mis
en valeur son expérience de plusieurs
postes en préfecture lors de son
audition par notre commission pour
expliquer combien il était qualifié pour
ce poste doit-on aujourd'hui considérer
que votre absence d'expérience de
terrain en ruralité pourrait vous
handicaper pour ce même poste quels
éléments pouvez-vous nous donner pour
nous rassurer sur sur le fait que vous
porterez une attention au territoire qui
ont le plus besoin de la NCT à savoir
les petites collectivités rurales
pour être plus positif j'observe qu'en
tant que directeur général des
collectivités locales vous avez assuré
la tutelle administrative de la NCT
depuis sa création notamment dans le
cadre du contrat d'objectif et de
performance qui lit la NCT omnister de
la cohésion des territoires vous êtes
donc censé connaître parfaitement le
fonctionnement interne de la NCT ce qui
est un avantage côté positif également
votre expérience au ministère de
l'intérieur et en particulier à la
direction générale des collectivités
nous assure du fait que vous maîtrisez
pleinement les ressorts des dotations
aux collectivités je pense en
particulier à la dotation de soutien à
l'investissement local la t-il et à la
dotation et qui demande des territoires
ruraux la DETR c'est un vrai point
positif à nos yeux car vous serez
mobilisés utilement ces dotations dans
le cadre de votre action s'il Parlement
confirme votre nomination j'en profite
donc pour vous poser une question à ce
sujet quel bilan faites-vous d'ailleurs
de l'action de l'agence après ses
premières années de fonctionnement
cela m'amène à faire la transition avec
les moyens humains et financiers de la
NCT au sujet desquels je souhaitais
également vous interroger d'abord deux
éléments sur les moyens propres de la
NCT puis un élément concernant les
opérateurs partenaires
s'agissant des moyens propres de la NT
son budget comprenant une subvention
pour charge de service public d'environ
60 millions d'euros interroge sur les
capacités réelles de cette agence au
sein du budget de la NCT une ligne
dédiée au soutien à l'ingénierie de
projet des collectivités inscrite elle
s'élevée à 10 millions d'euros la
première année de création de l'agence
puis elle est passée à 20 millions
d'euros
je rappelle que c'est pour l'ensemble du
territoire national bien évidemment sur
ce point je rend hommage à notre
excellent collègue Louis-Jean de Nicolaï
qui est juste derrière moi et qui garde
un œil attentif sur ce questionnement il
est notre rapporteur budgétaire pour
avis sur les crédits de plusieurs
programmes importants pour la cohésion
des territoires dont le programme sans
doute comportant les crédits de la NCT
et ils regrettait l'an dernier la
stabilité de cette ligne budgétaire quel
regard portez-vous donc sur le niveau de
ses moyens et pensez-vous qu'il soit
suffisant ou au contraire qu'il
mériterait d'être augmenté dans les
prochaines années
au-delà environ de la moitié des projets
soutenus par l'agence dans les
territoires bénéficient en réalité d'une
expertise externe allenct 25% des
projets sont soutenus par la
mobilisation des partenaires de l'agence
25% des projets reçoivent une subvention
directe de la NTT et l'expertise interne
de lagence ne serait mobilisés que pour
moins de 10% des projets soutenus nous
connaissons bien sûr les exigences du
droit européen qui imposent aux
administrations publiques de ne pas
intervenir là où il n'y a pas de carence
de l'initiative privée mais tout de même
les ce dont les communes rurales ont
besoin c'est d'un retour du conseil des
services déconcentrés au plus près du
terrain je comprends que des bureaux
d'études agissant dans le cadre d'un
marché cadre global conclu avec l'agence
intervienne mais qu'en est-il de
l'expertise des services de l'État qui
manient bien les dotations qui
connaissent les territoires le droit de
l'urbanisme les problèmes du terrain
deuxième question donc sur le volet des
moyens quel est votre vision de
l'ingénierie que devra apporter la NCT
au collectivités comment comptez-vous
développer les prestations d'ingénierie
en propre à la NCT et quelle
mutualisation imaginez-vous
éventuellement avec d'autres ingénérique
qui existent sur le terrain de la part
d'autres collectivités par exemple j'en
termine sur la question des moyens en
évoquant les opérateurs partenaires de
la NCT avec lesquels elle conclut des
conventions pluriannuelles portant
notamment sur les financements que ces
opérateurs mettent au service des
projets de l'agence je parlais de
l'ADEME du cerema de lanrup de Lana ou
de la Caisse des dépôts est
consignations les conventions
pluriannuelles doivent être transmises
au Parlement cette disposition figure
dans la loi avait été inscrite à
l'initiative du Sénat de notre
rapporteur Louis-Jean de Nicolaï elle ne
l'ont jamais été par la voie officielle
du secrétaire du Secrétaire général du
gouvernement en outre elle semble peu
précise et peu engageante pour les
opérateurs partenaires
dès lors dernière question quel regard
portez-vous sur l'engagement des
opérateurs partenaires de la NCT
sont-ils coopératifs selon vous comment
comptez-vous faire en sorte de respecter
la promesse qui avait été faite par le
Président de la République d'avoir un
véritable guichet unique pour les
projets des collectivités avec un
opérateur comme la NCT qui coordonne
voire absorbe les opérateurs de l'État
qui interviennent chacun dans leur champ
de compétences c'est un point
déterminant pour le fonctionnement et le
succès de l'agence je terminerai avec
une question plus large qui permettra je
l'espère à mes collègues autour de moi
de prolonger les échanges notre
commission cette dernier mois a publié
de nombreux rapports d'informations au
cours donc de cette période portant sur
des sujets variés tels que le soutien en
commerce en milieu rural la logistique
urbaine les déserts médicaux les ponts
et les ouvrages d'art sujet majeurs pour
nos collectivités pour la sécurité de
nos concitoyens et beaucoup d'autres
encore ma question est donc la suivante
quel est donc vous faire de toutes ces
bonnes la proposition allez vous vous
inspirez et finalement pour voir encore
plus largement quel est Monsieur le
Directeur Général votre conception de la
cohésion des territoires je vous
remercie
merci monsieur le rapporteur monsieur
boron je vous propose de
nous dire quelques mots pour liminaires
et de répondre au porteur et après je
viendrai la parade à mes collègues merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président je me
suis président monsieur le rapporteur
mesdames et messieurs les sénateurs et
qui mangent je suis devant vous pour à
la suite de la proposition du Président
de la République de me nommer comme
directeur général de la NCT et donc
soumis à votre accord évidemment et je
voudrais qu'on vous m'y inviter
peut-être dire quelques mots pour me
présenter vous avez monsieur rapporteur
merci beaucoup déjà aimablement donner
quelques éléments de mon parcours et
puis évoqué ensuite avec vous les enjeux
qui rejoindront par certains partis une
certaine aspects les éléments que vous
avez pu indiquer sur rapporteur sur la
façon dont je vois peut-être les choses
à mon niveau pour la NCT dans les
prochaines années
tout d'abord me présenter rapidement que
vous l'avez indiqué Monsieur le rapport
torche administrateur général de l'État
depuis une vingtaine d'années je suis
rentré au service de l'État
à disons ministère de l'intérieur mais
je n'ai pas fait exactement que ça vous
avez raison j'ai été aussi en
établissement public au début de ma
carrière et puis j'exerçais comme
souffre V pendant trois ans vous l'avez
souligné j'ai effectivement passé
beaucoup de temps dans ma carrière au
sein de la Direction générale des
collectivités locales une douzaine
d'années dans différents postes j'ai été
nommé le 15 juillet 2019 Jacqueline
Gouraud est en Ministre en charge comme
directeur général et donc est pris les
fonctions il y a maintenant un peu plus
de 3 ans comme vous le savez cette
direction générale qui est de taille
moyenne 200 agents s'occupe de
différents sujets nous travaillons
souvent avec vous sur les questions de
finance locale sur les questions de
compétences et aussi l'institution
locale mais aussi le statut des élus ou
des agents de la fonction publique
territoriale ça j'allais dire c'est le
classique de la compétence de la DGCL
sachant que depuis janvier 2020 des
compétences nouvelles ont été confiées à
la direction générale avec la reprise
des missions qui étaient exercées au
précédemment par le Cgep des missions
autour de l'aménagement de territoire et
de la politique de la ville et donc nous
exerçons depuis maintenant donc près de
3 ans en lien avec la NT mon expérience
professionnelle m'a permis de développer
plusieurs compétences qui je pense pour
être utile dans les fonctions de
directeur général de la NCT tout d'abord
je crois regarde mon parcours avoir une
bonne connaissance des questions portant
sur les relations état collectivités
locales
j'ai vu participer sous l'autorité des
différents ministres depuis une dizaine
d'années elle élaboration d'un nombre
certain nombre de textes relatifs ou
collectivités en commençant par la loi
RCT mais plus récemment
comme directeur général la loi
engagement et proximité et la loi 3DS
qui ont été marqués du saut de la
différenciation
au-delà de la participation à
l'élaboration et la préparation de ces
lois et de leur déclinaison
réglementaire nous travaillons chaque
année effectivement et c'est la période
sur les questions des finances locales
dans le cas des projets loi de finances
mais aussi faisons vivre l'ensemble des
dispositifs monsieur rapporteur vous
évoquez dotations d'investissement mais
c'est aussi que la mécanique de la DGF
que dont nous avons la responsabilité et
qui nous amène à être en contact courant
avec les services déconcentrés de l'État
mais aussi les élus l’activité la DGC ne
s'arrête pas à ça il faut savoir que au
quotidien nous travaillons
interministériel pour faire valoir dans
l'élaboration des politiques publiques
le point de vue des collectivités
locales et des élus locaux évidemment
c'est une sorte de schizophrénie nous
sommes d'un service de l'État mais nous
devons aussi faire valoir toute
importance que ces collectivités inscrit
dans la Constitution et les compétences
qu'elles exercent ont comme effet sur le
territoire
nous répondons aussi à bon nombre
d'interrogations de demandes d'appui de
conseils d'expertise qui émanent parfois
des parlementaires du Sénat mais aussi
des associations d'élus des préfets qui
nous sollicitent beaucoup et bien sûr
aussi des différentes instances dans
lesquelles nous nous sions ou dont nous
assurons le secrétariat comme le Comité
des finances locales ou le cnen ou le
CSFPT de cette expérience je crois avoir
pouvoir tirer une bonne maîtrise du
fonctionnement de l'État central comme
local des contraintes de
l'interministériel mais aussi et surtout
j'ai été amené à avoir un lien très
régulier et
j'allais dire constant avec les
parlementaires et les représentants des
élus au sein de leur association
évoquant à chaque fois des questions et
des difficultés rencontrées sur le
terrain par les collectivités c'est une
dimension indispensable pour
occuper les fonctions de direction la
NCT notamment de par sa composition avec
10 représentants d'associations d'élus
au sein du conseil d'administration mais
aussi quatre parlementaires et donc un
conseil d'administration et une mission
orienté vers les territoires il s'agisse
des collectivités comme des habitants
concernant le la NCT je crois et vous
l'avez indiqué Monsieur le rapporteur de
par les fonctions depuis deux années de
commissaire du Gouvernement près de la
NT avoir une petite idée de comment elle
fonctionne et de ses missions même si je
ne suis pas dedans j'exerçais la tutelle
depuis juillet 2019 j'ai en fait
participé avec les ex et qui du cget
aussi à la création l'installation de
l'agence
ça bascule et la fusion vers sa création
officielle au 1er janvier 2020 nous
avons accompagné donc activement pour ce
qui concerne les services et moi-même à
travers la tutelle qui nous a été
confiée la création et le déploiement de
l'ensemble des missions de la NCT et
j'ai participé depuis lors à tous les
conseils d'administration auprès de
l'ancienne présidente car une cailleux
est l'ancien directeur général il le
Breton et nous avons donc participé à la
mise en place de l'ingénierie sur mesure
des différents programmes ou du
lancement des CRPE
diriger un établissement public est
aussi église aussi des compétences de
management et de gestion il faut parler
réel et je crois de par mon parcours en
ayant été en fonction deux fois comme
directeur d'administration centrale
d'abord des RH du ministère d'intérieur
avec une équipe de 500 agents puis à la
DGCL en charge de 4g budgétaires vous
avez évoqué les dotations
d'investissement qui sont effectivement
des sujets très lourds pour nous mais
aussi le suivi du FNAT et des crédits la
politique de la ville depuis deux ans il
me semble remplir les conditions pour
pouvoir
m'occuper d'une direction générale d'une
agence composée de 345 agents de statut
variés et d'un budget qui atteint
aujourd'hui avec les crédits du plan de
relance plus de 150 millions d'euros
voilà pour mon parcours et les
compétences que je pense pouvoir mettre
à disposition de l'agence si vous me
donniez votre accord pour exercer ces
fonctions évidemment et dans le cadre
des orientations fixées par les
autorités ministérielles et le conseil
d'administration d'agence il y aura une
feuille de route à déterminer pour les
prochaines années mais à mon niveau et à
ce jour j'identifie déjà au moins deux
enjeux le premier c'est une question de
consolidation de l'agence
l'agence n'a que pas tout à fait 3 ans
deux ans et demi d'existence dont une
période qui était quand même largement
marquée par la crise du covid ce qui
n'est pas la période la plus simple
quand on veut installer une nouvelle
structure et aussi ensuite le lancement
du plan de relance qui a amené à un
déploiement on le verra d'initiative
très intéressante mais qui ont aussi pu
amener un certain nombre de de
difficultés dans le fonctionnement de
l'agence néanmoins malgré cela l'agence
a réussi à clairement porté sa mission
et être reconnu comme un ensemble billet
des politiques territoriales et un
fascitateur de projet comme c'était le
projet initial la fusion qui n'était pas
acquise entre une administration
centrale un service à compétence
nationale et un épique les Paracas a été
faite a été menée et s'est bien passé et
aujourd'hui le constat peut être fait
que les programmes territoriaux ont été
déployés de nouveau même ont été lancés
comme petite ville de main
sur mesure à trouver son essor et son
envol avec plus de 1100 territoires qui
ont été accompagnés le programme France
service a tenu ses engagements puisque
fin 2022 nous dépasserons le nous est un
collectif le pays dépassera 2500 espaces
en service déployés sur l'ensemble du
territoire les CRPE ont été créés lancés
et signés pour l'essentiel d'entre eux
sur tous les territoires le réseau
numérique tant sur le volet fibre que
sur le vélo mobile se déploie très
rapidement au bénéfice des populations
notamment des territoires ruraux et les
actions en matière de politique de la
ville comme sur la ruralité ou la
montagne ont connu un renouvellement une
dynamisation très appréciée par les
acteurs de terrain
la NCT s'est vu donc confié des missions
de plus en plus nombreuses avec de
nouveaux champs d'intervention notamment
dans le cadre du plan de relance les
conseils numériques seront servis ou le
font de restructuration des locaux
d'activités mais c'est aussi des fonds
européens qui ont été confiés notamment
le fond brexit et d'autres gestion de
fonds son budget ainsi doubler en deux
ans c'est une vraie poussette croissance
en fait en très peu de temps quel est
confrontée dans laquelle elle est
confrontée c'était l'argissement mérite
sans doute qu'on réfléchisse et qu'on
mette on adéquation son organisation
interne avec ses moyens et les missions
qu'on veut lui confier tout en gardant
l'objectif initial d'un établissement
agile et souple capable de s'adapter et
d'être en lien avec le territoire il y
aura donc des questions sans doute dans
cette période de consolidation à se
poser sur l'organisation interne en
favorisant les mutualisations des moyens
et les synergies entre programmes
il faudra aussi poursuivre j'y crois
beaucoup la déconcentration du
fonctionnement et la proche terrain de
l'agence
il y a une capacité de projection de
l'agence qui doit être renforcée vers le
terrain vers les départements et aussi
peut-être mieux asseoir le rôle des
délégués territoriaux des préfets ainsi
que l'implication le fonctionnement et
l'association j'allais dire de
l'ensemble des services de l'État
départementaux et régionaux dans le
fonctionnement de l'agence
néanmoins si les toits l'État doit être
plus présent sur ces questions là le
principe de subsidiarité notamment pour
la mise en oeuvre des dispositifs
d'ingénierie doit être bien préservé là
où il y a les moyens locaux on y
reviendra il n'y a pas de raison que
l'agence vienne prendre la place de ou
remplacer des actions ou des initiatives
qui peuvent être menées notamment par
l'intercommunalité des agences
techniques départementales les agences
d'urbanisme
après cette consolidation il me semble
qu'il y a une nouvelle étape
d'amplification de son action qui doit
être envisagée évidemment dans le cas
des orientations déterminées par les
budgets et les tentations ministérielles
en premier lieu il me semble que c'est
l'accompagnement sur mesure en
ingénierie qui doit être doit être
renforcé
c'est la clé et c'est le point d'entrée
de sa création la création de la NCT
c'était la capacité à accompagner sur
mesure des projets territoire sur le
terrain comme je vous le disais plus de
1100 territoires ont été accompagnés 400
projets de crpe ont été accompagnés par
la NCT aussi sur laquelle elle a pu
apporter sa plus-value néanmoins la
demande reste forte il y a des attentes
qui restent encore sensibles
la question est sans doute pas
simplement de savoir comme vous
l'indiquez monsieur le rapporteur
comment accéder à une prestation de
conseil d'un marché mais plus
globalement comment répondre à des
demandes de multiformes qui peuvent
apparaître sur le terrain et comment
arriver peut-être à les canaliser les
orienter les traiter il y a différentes
façons et je pense qu'il faut développer
la boîte à outils qui existent mais qui
est peut-être méconnu autour notamment
par exemple en commençant par la mise à
disposition de données dont les
observatoires de la NCT dispose
d'analyse territoriale pour objectiver
la situation d'un territoire la création
et la structuration des réseaux locaux
des services de l'État avec les autres
acteurs des collectivités locales ou des
agences intervenants au niveau
départemental c'est aussi renforcer
l'appui des cinq grands partenaires que
la loi a prévu ou les citiez monsieur le
rapporteur la banque des territoires
l'ADEME le céréma mais aussi l'ANAH et
la rue
doit être un acteur de la coordination
de l'offre d'ingénierie locale dans une
logique et dans une démarche effective
de guichet unique comme vous l’indiquez
concernant les programmes il s'agit de
poursuivre leur déploiement bien sûr et
ils ont connu un grand succès notamment
si on pense à action cœur de ville
territoire d'industrie petite ville de
demain qui ont créé des dynamiques
territoriales indéniables néanmoins ils
vont devoir tous tout comme les CRPE qui
peuvent avoir une approche d'intégrateur
de ces initiatives au niveau
intercommunal prendre mieux en compte
l'exigence de transition écologique
l'avantage c'est que ces programmes
constituent au niveau local des
communautés de travail qui interviennent
sur des champs et variées le logement
l'urbanisme l'activité commerciale
industrielle pour territoire industrie
les équipements et donc permettront par
une logique de projet d'arriver intégrer
les questions de transition écologique
de façon plus forte encore sobriété
foncières rénovation thermique de façon
à répondre aux objectifs que la France
est fixée le déploiement du fond vert
permettra évidemment d'apporter des
moyens aussi en investissement pour
accompagner ces dynamiques de
enfin en matière de ruralité comme de
politique de la ville il fera bien
évidemment sur l'autorité des ministres
compétents prendre en compte les
évaluations de l'agenda rural 1 et des
contrats de ville afin de relancer une
nouvelle génération d'outils répondant
aux attentes des territoires et surtout
dans une approche transversale et
interministérielle comme les comités
interministériels à la ville ou ruralité
le prévoir afin de couvrir l'ensemble du
spectre des problématiques rencontrées
par ces territoires
plus généralement et un peu en
conclusion je vous dirais que l'anxiété
doit rester à l'écoute des territoires
et approfondir et poursuivre un modèle
réactif et agile qui a réussi elle doit
être capable aussi d'analyser les
évolutions à venir des territoires et
proposer des stratégies aux autorités
ministérielles comme à son conseil
d'administration elle doit enfin
apporter des actions nouvelles qui
certes répondent à des besoins locaux
actuels mais aussi à des besoins qui
émergent je pense notamment aux outils
numériques qui doivent être adaptés au
territoire à travers des incubateurs de
projets par exemple mais aussi au
développement par exemple des mobilités
ou la
CB l'accès excusez-moi l'accessibilité
en milieu rural qui reste un enjeu
majeur notamment depuis la loi l'homme
et les prises de compétences par les
communautés de communes de compétences
en matière de mobilité
si ma candidature devait être retenue
j'essaierai de suivre ces orientations
ses enjeux tout en prenant évidemment en
compte les orientations que les
ministres et puis que vous m'indiquez
aujourd'hui et apporter mon expérience
et mes compétences dans cette dans cette
action voilà je voilà la fin de mon pour
vous monsieur le Président ici motorisé
je vais peut-être apporter quelques
réponses à ce que le rapporteur nous
proposait
tout d'abord monsieur le rapporteur vous
évoquez la question des du calendrier de
désignation de la présidence et la
direction générale on a une
configuration particulière à la NCT qui
est que la présidente a quitté ses
fonctions de présidence pour rentrer au
gouvernement donc au mois de au début de
l'été et le directeur général a été
nommé quelques semaines après dans de
nouvelles fonctions il convient dans les
deux cas de pourvoir à ces deux postes
alors comme vous le savez la présidence
est aujourd'hui occupée puisque le
vice-président est devenu président par
intérim donc il occupe les fonctions et
l'ensemble du conseil d'administration
doit être renouvelée d'ici la fin du
mois de novembre pour la réunion d'un
conseil d'administration de réélection
on va dire de la présidence le 13
décembre donc nous devons attendre le 13
décembre pour pouvoir réunir et désigner
un nouveau président c'est le calendrier
institutionnel que les textes prévoient
donc il n'est pas non plus anormal que
face à situation où la présidence par
intérim existent qu'il n'y a pas de
direction générale de chercher a aussi à
ce que les équipes soient début décembre
au complet présidente comme direction
générale et évidemment
nous nous adapterons les uns aux autres
il n'y a évidemment aucune aucune
ambiguïté là-dessus il s'agit d'un
couple Président Directeur Général qui
doit être le plus proche et sur une
ligne la plus la plus harmonieuse
possible évidemment c'est l'objectif
partagé qui sera partagé j'en suis
certain c'est aussi la seule solution
pour que l'agence progresse et continue
d'avancer dans de bonnes conditions
vous évoquez dans mon parcours l'absence
alors ou la faible expérience de terrain
précisément même si j'ai exercé trois
ans dans le département du Nord dans des
fonctions sous préfet à la ville qui
pour une grande partie dans le
département du Nord quand on parle du
Sud du Nord peuvent ressembler parfois à
des fonctions qui portent aussi un peu
sur la ruralité puisque nous avons des
territoires en politique de la ville qui
ont des configurations qui ne sont pas
du tout celles par exemple de
l'Île-de-France qui sont des petites
communes ex ouvrières si je cite
aujourd'hui la commune de Fourmies par
exemple qui sont aujourd'hui classés en
politique de la ville je crois donc
avoir tiré de ces trois plus de trois
ans sur ce terrain une expérience très
riche de contact d'abord avec les élus
locaux les associations et d'avoir
essayé de porter à mon niveau et dans
mes moyens qui est les moyens qui
étaient les miens bon nombre de projets
pour essayer de faire avancer ces
territoires avec l'ensemble des acteurs
depuis lors j'ai toujours gardé une très
grande attention à toutes les questions
qui ne du terrain
je suis sans doute un quelqu'un qui
vient plutôt de la centrale comme on dit
dans notre jargon néanmoins je suis pour
beaucoup lié à un ministère qui est le
ministère de l'Intérieur qui est le
ministère aussi des territoires qui est
en lien constant avec les sous-prés les
préfets et comme je vous le disais nous
passons beaucoup de temps à informer les
services des concentrés des actions que
nous menons pour les collectivités
locales GCL être en remontée permanente
des difficultés rencontrées et depuis au
moins
2019 nous travaillons très couramment
avec les secrétaires d'État ou les mises
en charge des ruralité Joël Giraud par
exemple madame Faure aujourd'hui tout
comme ceux en charge la politique de la
ville au regard de nos compétences
maintenant à la DGCL en matière
d'aménagement territoire et de politique
de la ville
sur la question du bilan de l'agence
après ses premières années je crois par
mon propos un peu introductif avoir
donné à une réponse à cette question je
vous dirais que le bilan il est positif
l'agence a réussi dans des conditions
très particulières que je crois que tout
le monde doit se remémorer en partant
d'une situation très délicate la fusion
de trois établissements de trois
structures de nature très différentes
avec des missions très différentes elle
a réussi cette synthèse cette créer
cette dynamique et mettre en place
programme ingénierie contrat qui était
ce que la loi lui avait prévu lui avait
demandé de faire donc la mission était
accomplie il reste à faire cette rupture
a même pas trois ans évidemment il reste
beaucoup à faire mais en trois années
que de parcours à accompli et je
reconnais que l'ensemble des agents
comme les équipes qui ont été à la
manœuvre pendant cette période peuvent
aujourd'hui être assez satisfait
concernant les moyens alors évidemment
nous ne sommes pas là dans une audition
budgétaire donc je serai pas
complètement en mesure d'apporter des
réponses sont-ils suffisants doivent-ils
augmenter la subvention pour charges de
service public à peu près 60 millions
d'euros comme vous l'indiquez qui est
versé par les tâches chaque année est
une subvention qui couvre uniquement on
va dire le fonctionnement de l'agence
c'est le la conception de l'agence au
point de départ ça couvre les charges de
personnel les dépenses de fonctionnement
et l'ingénierie la ligne de 20 millions
aujourd'hui des d'aides à l'ingénierie
qui peut être mobilisée et qui est qui
rencontre un vrai succès puisque
aujourd'hui en octobre 2022 je crois que
déjà 15 millions d'euros ont été dédiés
aux ingénierie sur mesure sur le
territoire sachant qu'il y a
l'ingénierie en plus dans les programmes
par exemple vous savez qu'il y a des
charges mission petites vieux demain pas
loin de 900 aujourd'hui qui sont aussi
pris en charge mais qui ne sont pas pour
une grande partie dans le budget de la
NCT
la particularité de la NCT effectivement
c'est que ça n'est pas une agence qui
comme l'enru a on va dire agréger
l'ensemble des financements extérieurs
et ensuite les redéploient c'est une
agence qui reste une agence de mission
avec un budget modeste et qui a un rôle
de coordination d'autres acteurs quand
on voit le système de action corps de
ville en fait les grands acteurs du
financement des 5 milliards du programme
sont Action Logement Lana par exemple
d'autres acteurs l'état évidemment à
travers cette notation d'investissement
mais ce sont pas des financements qui
sont dans l'agence donc c'est une
particularité dans sa constitution qui
la rend effectivement assez atypique
mais qui la rend légère c'est à dire
elle n'est pas inscrit dans des
structures de gestion dans le logique de
gestion néanmoins la question des moyens
sont-ils suffisants ou pas ils sont
encore un peu tôt pour moi pour en juger
en tant que je ne suis pas dans ces
fonctions là mais il me semble que selon
l'émission et les objectifs qui lui
seront antibués nécessairement la
question de avons dispositif de son de
son organisation devra être posée
sur l'expertise
quelle est la vision sur l'ingénierie
comment quel ingénierie ou quel
mutualisation en matière d'ingénierie va
apporter la NTT
l'ingénierie aujourd'hui elle peut avoir
différentes comme je vous le disais
différentes approches tout d'abord il
faut s'assurer que au niveau local il y
a bien une absence de réponse possible
première élément deuxième élément c'est
comment
la NCT peut apporter une plus-value il
s'agit pas de vouloir plaquer des
systèmes nationaux sur des initiatives
ou des projets locaux concrètement c'est
cette logique de guichet unique qui est
à développer et il s'agit à travers cela
de mutualiser des moyens locaux et je
crois beaucoup notamment au comité
locaux de cohésion territoriale qui sont
dans chaque département prévu par les
textes et qui doivent autour du préfet
associer l'ensemble des acteurs je pense
notamment département aux
intercommunalités au cieux on a aussi
des SEMS et des SPL aujourd'hui présente
dans bon nombre de territoires qui ont
des capacités notamment sur l'ingénierie
opérationnelle pour mettre en oeuvre les
projets parce que souvent on nous dit ah
mais c'est bien on a pu concevoir le
projet grâce à un soutien mais
maintenant on a du mal à le mettre en
oeuvre donc c'est cette question de
l'articulation d'ingénierie et je pense
qu'au niveau c'est au niveau
départemental ponctuellement avec un
soutien régional effectivement si besoin
était qu'il faut se poser les questions
des acteurs et des outils en soutien des
territoires
concernant les les conventions qui doit
être transmises entre les grands
partenaires et la NCT
m'assurer le cas échéance si je devais
rejoindre à NTT des conditions dans
lesquelles ces conventions ont été ou
pas transmises au Parlement bien sûr
comme les textes le prévois je vous
rejoins sur le fait que de toute façon
nous arrivons au bout des trois années
de leur signature donc elles doivent
être renouvelées et qu'il y aura et
c'est bien normal trois années après il
y a eu le temps de changements être
réinterroger pour un certain nombre
d'acteurs prenons un exemple le serema
la loi 3DS a modifié aujourd'hui son
fonctionnement en permettant aux
collectivités d'adhérer au CMA donc dans
une prestation inhouse et donc ça a
changé complètement les conditions dans
lesquelles on peut mobiliser le céréma
dans le cas de d'une ingénierie
notamment de haut niveau ou technique
donc il y aura cette question à reposer
dans les conventions et je suis sûr que
l'ensemble des acteurs seront soucieux
de prendre en compte l'expérience des
trois années pour avoir des conventions
peut-être plus précises plus engageante
sur comment on s'organise pour mettre en
oeuvre ces guichets d'ingénierie pour
les territoires
quelle est ma conception de la cohésion
des territoires pour conclure vaste
sujet monsieur le rapporteur j'ai peur
de pas être suffisamment
enfin de pas de pas vouloir prendre trop
de temps de cette audition la cohésion
des territoires
c'est ce qu'il a de plus
interministériel aujourd'hui sans doute
notre politique
publique c'est l'ensemble et c'est bien
la difficulté de cette de cette
dimension c'est que elle exige de mettre
en œuvre et de mettre en action
l'ensemble des leviers dont disposons en
matière de politiques publiques
territorialisée
puisque la cohésion territoire concerne
tant les territoires
urbains que les territoires ruraux voire
des territoires qui vont très bien pour
savoir comment ils peuvent aussi je
pense au contrat de réciprocité aider
les territoires dans leur environnement
qui vont moins bien c'est comment le
développement de certains de ses pas au
détriment d'autres donc c'est tout un
système qui repose tant sous des outils
financiers de péréquation le cas échéant
au-dessous tiens au collectivités ou
territoire les plus en difficulté qu'un
dispositif qui encourage les territoires
en difficulté ou ceux qui vont bien à se
développer et à créer une dynamique
territoriale économique et sociale voilà
c'est sans doute de façon un peu
simplifiée mais c'est un champ d'action
qui est profondément interministériel et
qui exige de travailler en
transversalité tant au niveau national
entre les différents ministères les
différents acteurs qu'au niveau local
entre les différentes collectivités
locales Région Département
intercommunalité et communes et aussi
les autres acteurs du monde économique
ou social
merci je vais donner la parole à
Stéphane demi
merci monsieur le Président bonjour
monsieur Bouron
l'Agence nationale de la cohésion des
territoires à pour mission de réduire
les inégalités entre les territoires au
travers de la politique publique
territoire et ruralité et de la
gendarmerie rurale en 2019 l'agenda
rural proposait par le gouvernement
comportait 180 une mesure abordant la
désertification médicale le soutien des
petits commerçants ou encore la
résorption des zones blanches de
téléphonie mobile
selon un communiqué de presse du
gouvernement
93,5% des mesures de relance des
territoires ont été réalisés ou sont en
cours de lettres
93,5% ce taux de réussite est à
relativiser très largement et pour tout
vous dire il fait sourire ironiquement
de nombreux mères les déserts médicaux
contraignent encore trop souvent nos
concitoyens à renoncer à leur soin des
mesures devaient être prises comme le
déploiement des stages d'internes en
médecine dans les zones rurales
soudances mais ça n'a jamais été mis en
place la difficulté d'accès aux soins
fragilisés et isolent les habitants des
zones rurales et cette gangrène gagne de
plus en plus les petites villes hier on
me citer l'exemple d'habitants de
Chantilly qui ne trouvent pas un médecin
de disponible à cela s'ajoute l'accès
aux services publics après avoir renoncé
à leur soin nos concitoyens doivent
parfois renoncer effectivement à leurs
droits et les 2000 maisons de services
publics ne règlent pas tous les
problèmes face bien sûr au 32 000
communes
à l'époque de la création de la NCT
j'avais fait part de mon scepticisme à
l'Assemblée nationale quant à l'intérêt
de ce nouvel outil
Monsieur le Directeur potentiel comment
allez-vous agir pour que l'anct ne soit
pas un grand machin de plus qui ne se
limite pas à un rôle d'observatoire en
faisant des constats passifs de ce que
les autres font
merci
[Musique]
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général si on va ce matin sur
le site de la NCT dans la rubrique offre
d'emploi 17 propositions sont visibles
toutes sont basées à Paris
c'est assez représentatif du ressenti
des territoires c'est-à-dire une
impression que tout se passe à Paris
alors que les attendent toujours plus
d'ingénierie sur les territoires ma
question est très simple quel est votre
stratégie pour éviter ce sentiment et
parfois cette réalité que la nctent
merci chers collègues la parole est à
Jean-Michel Houlgate merci merci
monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur Général vous avez une
connaissance fine des collectivités
locales et des enjeux auxquels sont
confrontés dans un contexte et vous
l'avez souligné ou les territoires les
plus fragiles sont en décrochage
décrochage en milieu rural et nos
collègues
ils les ont mentionnés mais décrochage
aussi en milieu urbain dans les
quartiers prioritaires de la politique
de la ville alors nous sommes dans la
quatrième décennie des politiques
publiques en faveur des quartiers
prioritaires vous étiez je vais dire
pratiquement encore en primaire quand le
rapport Schwartz bonne maison ou de
Bedous sont sortis au début des années
des années 80 on a connu le
développement social des quartiers les
contrats de ville les contrats urbains
de cohésion sociale l'action cœur de
ville on a presque tout essayé et je
pense que c'est vrai que nous devons
faire preuve dans ce domaine de beaucoup
d'humilité quel est votre analyse du
bilan des politiques qui ont été menées
en faveur des quartiers prioritaires et
vous venez d'annoncer donc une nouvelle
génération d'outils qui balayait donc
l'ensemble
du spectre des problématiques à résoudre
donc elles sont donc les nouveaux
leviers qu'il faut activer ou la
nouvelle méthode de façon à réduire
cette fracture territoriale que nous
connaissons en milieu urbain
merci je vais donner la parole à
Guillaume chevrolier puis après je vous
propose de répondre et j'ai encore
quatre collègues qui ont demandé la
parole oui merci monsieur le Président
Monsieur bon vous l'avez dit l'agence
nationale au cohésion des territoires et
un outil au service des collectivités
locales et les plus petites en ont le
plus besoin et sont parfois éloignés on
a besoin pour la revitalisation des
centres-bourgs pour façonner les
territoires du 21e du 21e siècle en
tenant compte des enjeux climatiques et
de la décarbonation alors la question
c'est comment mieux soutenir les
territoires les plus ruraux les plus
fragiles qui ont un fort besoin
d'ingénierie vous avez parlé
d'accompagnement
sur mesure c'est effectivement ce qu'il
faut faire donc vous serez très attendu
sur sur ce point là
dans un contexte budgétaire qui est
contraint vu notre niveau d'endettement
les agences d'État se doivent
d'optimiser la ressource publique et à
cette fin quelle proposition vous
formulez pour mieux coordonner mieux
mutualiser les actions qui sont menées
par la NCT qui sont également menées par
la dame et le céréma qui parfois sont
des actions qui qui se chevauchent et
parfois pire il y a double emploi vous
avez évoqué les les conventions mais
quelle stratégie vous souhaitez avoir
pour vraiment limiter et optimiser cette
coordination entre les agences d'État
merci
merci et je vous propose de répondre à
mes collègues de mini gold Houlgate et
chevrolier merci beaucoup monsieur le
président
alors monsieur le sénateur de mi alors
sur la question de l'agenda rural alors
je vous trouve un peu dur même si je
crois que vous avez souligné un point
qui ressort et qui est très objectif
c'est la question de la autour de la
santé la problématique médicale qui est
d'ailleurs un sujet qui aujourd'hui ne
touche plus que le monde oral est en
train de se déployer ailleurs j'ai
entendu des propos notamment de la mise
en charge indiquant qu'on avait quand
même 80% du territoire qui rencontrait
de près ou de loin des difficultés
d'accès à la santé je serais très
modeste je crois pas que la n'était
pourra régler à elle seule les questions
sur la démographie médicale néanmoins
néanmoins on sait bien qu'aujourd'hui
une bonne partie des initiatives locales
autour des maisons de santé contribuent
dans bon nombre de territoires à réduire
les difficultés voire parfois recréer
une dynamique pour attirer dans des
pôles qui correspondent aux attentes des
professionnels de la santé notamment
avec une mutualisation des moyens avec
différents types de métiers de
infirmière kiné et puis médecin au même
endroit donc on voit qu'il y a des
outils la loi 3DS a aussi ouvert un
certain nombre de dispositions
facilitant pour les collectivités
locales les recrutements et la mise en
place de ces maisons de santé et leur
financement donc on voit que il y a des
actions qui peuvent être menées que
l'agence peut aussi à travers son
ingénierie aider au portage et puis
après il y a écrit l'investissement de
l'État qui peut intervenir pour déployer
ce type de projet en lien avec les ARS
sur l'accès aux services publics plus
globalement je crois qu'il faut quand
même reconnaître qu'aujourd'hui on est à
80 plus de 95% de la population qui a un
accès quand même dans des délais très
courts à un espace rend service
évidemment ça ne vient pas contredire
l'accès aux communes qui elle aussi ont
un maillage d'hyperproximité mais on
sait qu'on a un niveau de prestation
aujourd'hui avec les 9 grands opérateurs
de France service très attractifs qui
permettent de répondre à bon nombre de
questions sur le quotidien des des
usagers des administrés et 80% des qui
sont posées dans ces espaces sont
aujourd’hui traités directement et
intégralement dans ces espaces ce qui
veut dire que c'est pas un renvoi vers
quelqu'un d'autre évidemment parfois le
sujet très complexe il y a forcément à
renvoyer vers je sais pas la CPAM ou la
CAF mais dans la plupart des cas il y a
une proximité vis-à-vis des
habitants et une capacité à répondre à
apporter une réponse de proximité
la NTT ne sera pas un grand machin de
plus si je dois être directeur général
mon parcours m'amène à voir une vision
assez différente des choses et je crois
pas qu'elle l'est aujourd'hui et je
crois pas qu'elle le deviendra personne
n'y intéresse et vous pouvez compter en
tout cas sur mon engagement pour
qu'elles ne prennent pas ce chemin là si
je devais prendre des fonctions de
directeur général
sur les questions de décentralisation
des moyens le sénateurs gold alors
aujourd'hui la NCT
345 postes on va dire vous en avez
effectivement une soixantaine qui sont
hors de Paris à peu près 20% d'effectifs
aujourd'hui de n'est pas à Paris il se
trouve où vous avez une localisation à
Lille les agents qui travaillent dans ce
qu'on était l'ancien n'est parka vous
avez des localisations ensuite dans les
massifs c'est les commissariats de
massifs qui sont attachés à la NCT qui
travaillent au plus proche notamment
pour toute la thématique autour de la
montagne ou des ruralités en montagne
faut-il aller plus loin dans la
décentralisation ou le transfert de
moyens il y a il peut y avoir des débats
à mon sens aujourd'hui avec les systèmes
de visioconférence de télétravail les
moyens de transport c'est autant la
question de la capacité de projection
que la question d'être présent à temps
plein sur le terrain la capacité à être
avoir des référents territoriaux mieux
identifiés plus nombreux et qui sont
capables d'aller sur le terrain
rencontrer les acteurs locaux aux côtés
du préfet ou du DDT c'est ça mon avis
l'enjeu c'est ça qu'il faut déployer il
y a déjà une petite équipe aujourd'hui
mon sentiment au jour où je vous parle
c'est qu'il faut aller plus loin
là-dessus et avoir des profils qui
soient des profils de gens qui peuvent
aller en contact du terrain soutenir les
projets
habiter le cas échéon sur le terrain en
l'occurrence sur ces territoires ou pas
le sujet à la limite est peut-être pas
le plus important l'important c'est
capacité de projection des moyens de
soutien vis-à-vis des territoires
monsieur le sénateur Houlgate sur les
questions des milieux urbains
les bilans sur les actions poétiques de
la ville alors je remettrai pas je
causes années 70 et 80 effectivement on
a engagé et sous l'autorité des
ministres en charge un certain nombre
d'évaluation des contrats de vie qui
s'achève vous savez que les contrats de
ville comme au centre de zonage s'achève
à la fin 2023 donc nous sommes dans une
phase où l'ensemble des notamment des
territoires ont été interrogés pour
faire remonter leur analyse leur bilan
de ce qui fonctionne de ce qui
fonctionne moins bien ça rentre de
choses apparaissent par exemple
la question des nouveaux projets et des
nouveaux programmes comme les cités
éducatives les cités de l'emploi sont
salués reconnus comme très utile la le
zonage des qpv considéré comme assez
pertinent même si il y a encore des
efforts à faire pour le rapprocher
d'autres zonage notamment d'éducation
nationale
un point apparaît à ce stade c'est la
question de l'Association des
populations dans la guerre qui est
populaire et leur participation aux
actions c'est un point qui remonte
aujourd'hui
aujourd'hui de du terrain
cette synthèse est en train d'être faite
évidemment il y a un ministre en charge
de ces affaires-là qui prendra ensuite
les décisions nécessaires et les
orientations seront prises par le
gouvernement néanmoins je peux déjà vous
dire que les efforts qui sont autour des
sujets que l'ancien puisque la NCT est
quelque part une lointaine successeuse
de la DIV la délégation intermittelle à
la ville et donc a une compétence forte
et les effectifs très impliqués sur les
questions politiques de la ville et ont
porté beaucoup de projets qui ont connu
comme je vous disais c'estugatif c'était
de l'emploi un vrai succès travailler
aussi en interface avec l'enru comme
c'est prévu par les textes qui elle
intervient avec son PNRU et le NP NRU
nouveau programme de rénovation urbaine
avec 12 milliards mobilisés sur les
territoires pour requalifier des
territoires urbains c'est un enjeu très
important et donc là aussi à mon sens et
au niveau de la NCT c'est cette
interaction à renforcer entre le
bâtiment terre c'est un peu simpliste
comme présentation et le le
fonctionnement du quartier qui doit être
toujours on doit être très attentif à ce
que les deux fonctionnent ensemble et au
mieux
monsieur le sénateur chevalier sur les
questions l'optimisation des ressources
publiques et les mutualisations entre
les établissements comme je vous le
disais nous arrivons au bout des termes
de la première génération de convention
avec les grands opérateurs tels que la
loi l'avait prévu
il est vous évoquez le céréma l'ADEM il
s'agit effectivement d'éviter les
chevauchement les doubles emploi je
pense qu'on a pu voir aujourd'hui les
j'évoquais aussi les évolutions de
statut du CMA qui a besoin de recaler un
certain nombre de d'interventions c'est
ce qui doit être fait dans les mois qui
viennent et donc l'ensemble des
opérateurs auront assigné ces nouvelles
conventions qui prévoieront
nécessairement la limitation voir la
suppression idéalement de de
boulons évidemment mais surtout je pense
la meilleure articulation des
interventions des uns et des autres on
voit bien aujourd'hui la N c'était
intervient sur son de champ mais elle ne
peut pas tout faire et d'ailleurs elle
n'a pas vocation à tout faire vocation
de coordination d'orientation
d'interface
à l'inverse on a des acteurs qui sont
très spécialisés qui ont des vrais
compétences sur des thématiques et cela
il faut qu'ils puissent être mobilisés
quand le sujet le demande d'ingénierie
est vraiment de leur ressort et que il
n'y ait pas une dispersion de
sollicitations ou d'intervention qui
donne le renvoi le sentiment au
territoire que tout ceci un peu le bazar
voilà donc il y a vraiment cette
dimension qui doit être prise en compte
dans les dans les futurs conventions et
je pense que l'ensemble des équipes des
directions générales de ces
établissement ils travailleront du
travailleront ensemble si je devais de
mon côté rejoindre la NCT bien sûr
merci chez de la parole à Madame filleul
le Président Monsieur Bouron sans
pardonnez-moi sans reprendre les
interventions pertinentes de mes de mes
collègues ni remettre en question votre
bilan très élogieux de la NCT mais c'est
fort légitime de là où vous êtes je
voulais reprendre les éléments de
Monsieur Houlgate pour dire que
aujourd'hui en matière d'aménagement du
territoire le sentiment d'un certain
nombre d'élus que nous sommes et bien
que la politique d'aménagement du
territoire est un empilement de
programme je crois dans le budget pas
moins de 29 la juxtaposition de
dispositif mais on a du mal à voir ce
qu'on peut appeler aujourd'hui on
appelle couramment à un récit ou on ne
voit pas qu'elle est l'exigence qui est
la vôtre de d'égalité ou de recherche
d'égalité des territoires ensuite
reprendre ce que monsieur le rapporteur
à propos de l'ingénierie mais ce n'est
pas nouveau c'est vraiment la demande
qui est la demande prégnante de tous les
élus aussi bien pour ce qui concerne la
rénovation énergétique des bâtiments que
l'accélération des dernières énergies
renouvelables sur laquelle nous
travaillons or il s'avère que les moyens
dédiés au soutien des collectivités
territoriales en matière d'ingénierie
n'ont pas évolué depuis la création de
la NCT
et hors dispositif action cœur de ville
ou petite ville de demain et bien
finalement le nombre de communes qui est
touché quand même relativement
relativement faible et donc enfin
troisième élément je voulais vous poser
une question beaucoup plus précise sur
la question de l'inclusion numérique
puisque la NCT a été chargée de déployer
le dispositif des aidants numériques et
va continuer à l'être puisque on annonce
une deuxième vague des dents numériques
et je voulais je voulais vous faire
connaître l'inquiétude donc des aidants
numériques aujourd'hui en poste mais
également des grandes associations
grandes structures qui en ont recruté
sur le devenir la pérennisation de ces
postes et vous faire savoir également
que ces dispositifs apparaissent bien
j'allais dire anodin mais peut-être
est-ce que je suis excessive par rapport
à l'ampleur de la tâche puisqu'on dit
qu'aujourd'hui 50 des Français et bien
ne maîtrise pas tous les dispositifs
numériques d'accès en particulier à
leurs droits comment est-ce que vous
allez compléter ces dispositifs
merci chers collègues la parole de
Monsieur gilet
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur le
Directeur général je vous ai écouté avec
beaucoup d'attention tout d'abord au
préalable je suis toujours surpris dans
le cadre de ces auditions parce que nous
manque toujours des éléments
d'appréciation par rapport à
l'engagement personnel que vous aurez au
sein de la NCT c'est bien sûr les badges
où sont favorables à savoir quand on n'a
pas eu de communication d'une feuille
d'une feuille de route qui nous
permettrait vraiment de définir quels
sont les attendus aujourd'hui au travers
de votre poste alors qu'on est à un
moment clé quelque part comme vous
l'avez souligné puisque il y a un passé
il faut reprocher la NCT par rapport à
des nouveaux enjeux et donc ces enjeux
vous l'avez vous exprimé mais la
structure en elle-même ne l'a pas
exprimé ou ne nous a pas communiqué ce
qui est des éléments un peu manquants si
vous voulez pour pouvoir juger
véritablement de votre positionnement
mais vous avez apporté quelques
éclairages sur le sujet je voudrais
revenir sur un l'un d'entre eux en
l'occurrence il me semble que
l'évaluation aujourd'hui n'est pas
suffisamment partagée au niveau de
l'agence nationale vous savez toujours
quand on est dans des discours ultra
positifs à un moment donné quand on veut
vendre quelque part une structure qui
est quand même relativement nouvelle
mais il faut avoir une approche critique
au sens très positif du terme donc
regardez ce qui a marché ce qui n'a pas
bien marché et regardez comment on peut
se projeter vous avez souligner quelques
aspects par rapport à ça mais pour ce
qui nous concerne nous n'avons pas de
documents véritablement d'évaluation
aujourd'hui qui nous permettrait de
juger si cette évaluation est
suffisamment partagée aussi sur
l'ensemble des territoires vous avez
évoqué un sujet qui à mon sens est
majeur celui de la coopération et des
conventions alors vous avez parlé des
conventions avec les agences d'État et
les moyens de l'État bien sûr mais il y
a aussi les conventions qui devraient
être passées en fait avec l'ensemble des
collectivités territoriales qui
développent une ingénierie territoriale
et ses conventions sont très pauvres
aujourd'hui ou même quasi inexistante
alors certes vous mettez en perspective
toujours que dans certains territoires
bien dotés la N n'a pas vocation
intervenir j'en suis moins sûr pour ma
part je pense que si en l'occurrence
parce que il y a toujours à créer des
agilités avec les ingénieries d'État en
l'occurrence même sur des des
territoires bien dotés et on pourrait
attendre des
cadcap justement qu'elle permet de
définir des priorités partagées entre
l'État les collectivités territoriales
qui permettraient de se mobiliser sur
des projets communs des projets partagés
et là NCT pourrait intervenir avec une
plus-value j'en suis persuadé même si
ces territoires sont d'ores et déjà bien
dotés en ingénierie et enfin on y voit
pas toujours très clair vous l'avez
évoqué aussi le sujet sur le guichet
comment l'organisme comme on organise le
point d'entrée et comment on travaille
en mode projet avec l'ensemble des
années territoriales et d'état et
notamment sur les saisines territoriales
je pense que pour ma part l'ingénierie
au-delà des communes et des intercos
doit se développer aussi au niveau des
syndicats mixtes des territoires des
pôles d'équilibre territoriaux ruraux et
j'aimerais avoir votre avis sur le sujet
je vous remercie
merci chers collègues je donne la parole
à Frédéric marchand merci monsieur le
Président Monsieur Bron vous avez
employé les mots de coordination
orientation interface le mot assemblée
aussi aurait pu être employé puisque moi
je conçois la NCT effectivement qu'un
assemblée sur les territoires et on voit
bien aujourd'hui ça a été dit aussi par
nombre de collègues que les difficultés
d'ingénierie des petites collectivités
sont assez nombreuses aujourd'hui les
crédits qui ont été déployés par le plan
France relance ont permis là aussi
d'initier nombre de projets certains ne
se sont trouvés un peu gênés aux
entournures faisant au passage le
bonheur de nombre de cabinets conseils
et de cabinets d'études et parmi les
enjeux que vous avez évoqués dans votre
feuille de route il en est un qui me
paraît tout à fait important et sur
lequel effectivement la NCT pourrait se
pencher qui est cet agrégation des
données finalement puisque on a
aujourd'hui beaucoup de données qui
existent dans notre pays qu'on a un vrai
problème de transversalité dès lors
qu'il s'agit d'assembler toutes ces
données pourrait-on imaginer justement
sur des sujets comme celui de
l'alimentation durable des clients qui
est aujourd'hui un vrai sujet avec les
projets alimentaires territoriaux qu'à
un moment donné la NCT souhaite être
espèce d'agrégateur de données qui
permettent aux territoires finalement
d'avoir des photographies de réalité
qu'ils ont beaucoup de mal aujourd'hui à
obtenir sauf à passer par des cabinets
d'études et dégager des sommes tout à
fait substantielles merci
merci chers
merci monsieur le Président Monsieur
Bouron d'abord je voudrais dire que
j'abonde tout à fait dans le sens de ce
que notre collègue gilet vient de dire
sur les les éléments d'appréciation qui
nous faudrait pour la vie que nous
allons être amenés à donner sur votre
nomination alors j'ai deux trois
questions sur lesquelles vous avez déjà
en partie apporté quelques éléments mais
qui méritent peut-être approfondir
d'abord bien sûr sur sur le les gros
besoins d'ingénierie surtout dans la
transition écologique énergétique dans
la question de l'adaptation changement
climatique particulièrement pour les
petites collectivités donc comment
renforcer cette offre la rendre plus
accessible évitez qu'elle touche plutôt
ceux qui en aurait bien moins besoin
parce qu'ils ont déjà des réponses
possibles la question qui a pas été
abordée je crois encore de la de la
place du du niveau régional dans le
fonctionnement de la NCT dont si j'ai
bien compris c'est c'est essentiellement
entre le siège et les départements que
ça se joue parce que le niveau régional
c'est quand même le niveau des grands
opérateurs nationaux partenaires de la
NCT l'ADEME la banque des territoires le
cerema c'est aussi avec le Conseil
régional que ce négocie les
décontractualisations très structurantes
donc elle place au niveau régional dans
le fonctionnement de la NCT
et enfin non c'est tout pour l'essentiel
c'est tout
je vais donner la parole à Renan Dantec
merci Jacques oui merci monsieur le
Président je voudrais peut-être entendre
vous en avez un tout petit peu parlé
c'est un peu iptique sur sur les moyens
dédiés par la NTT à la transition
écologique et énergétique selon discuter
cette semaine au Sénat notamment du
développement des énergies renouvelables
en remettant les territoires au cœur de
cette stratégie ce qui veut dire que ces
territoires vont devoir être finement
accompagnés accompagné par exemple sur
la définition des zones propices
à ce développement tout cela va
nécessiter beaucoup de moyens humains
dans les territoires il en faudra aussi
beaucoup sur la rénovation énergétique
il en faut
donc énormément alors là vous dites les
cm dans certains cas pourront intervenir
j'ai bien entendu votre propos mais on
voit pas quand même les scènes des
elles-mêmes définir les zones propices
alors madame borne puisque vous avez
parlé d'investissement sur le fond vert
dans les échanges qu'on a pu avoir avec
elle évoque l'idée qu'une partie du fond
vert ne soit pas de l'investissement
mais du fonctionnement c'est quelque
chose qui semble ouvert aujourd'hui on
en rediscutera en loi de finance donc
comment vous voyez-vous le
dimensionnement réel des moyens humains
de la SCT avec des enjeux qui ne sont
pas méta c'est-à-dire qu'ils sont à
l'échelle de chaque projet et c'est à
l'échelle de chaque projet
qu'aujourd'hui les communes et les
petites intercommunalités n'arrivent pas
à trouver les moyens donc là j'aimerais
vous réentendre sur ce point en lien
évidemment avec l'accompagnement sur les
RTE comme contrat intégrateur point sur
lequel a priori nous sommes plutôt en
accord
merci chers collègues je vais donner la
parole à Jean-Claude Anglard qui va vous
parler je pense désert médicaux merci
monsieur le Président j'avais deux
questions vous avez parlé heureusement
des commissariats de massif et donc je
voulais voir avoir un peu votre point de
vue sur le sujet sur l'organisation tels
qui sont aujourd'hui l'évolution qu'il
devrait avoir notamment un lien avec les
préfets de départements mais c'est votre
sentiment là-dessus première question et
deuxième question c'est par rapport au
fond vert vous en avez parlé moi je
milite pour que le fond vert soit
notamment par rapport à un sujet qui
nous préoccupe et qui
occupe beaucoup les maires qui est la
sobriété foncière plutôt les ânes et
donc je pense que cela sobriété foncière
on doit avoir une politique volontariste
et je fais partie de ceux qui militent
pour que le fond vert soit à la main des
préfets non pas sous forme d'appel à
projet mais sauf au préfet pour que les
élus les collectivités locales puissent
rapidement rentrer dans le sujet de la
sobriété foncière notamment à travers la
reconquête des bourses des villages etc
etc merci
merci Monsieur Bron je vous laisse le
soin de répondre à mes collègues merci
beaucoup monsieur le Président Madame
fille elle vous évoquez les questions
d'empilement de programme effectivement
de démultiplication de programmes alors
il est vrai que on a un certain nombre
de programmes la logique de programme
c'est beaucoup déployé ces derniers
temps c'est une question qui je pense
pourra trouver une des éléments de
réponse dans le déploiement des CRPE les
CRPE vise doit viser parce que on sait
que certains sont plus avancés que
d'autres dans la réalité de ce qu'il
contiennent à être des contrats
intégrateurs avoir une dimension
intégrée le projet de territoire sur
soit l'intercommunalité soit dans son
intercommunalité qui se sont regroupés
pour faire ce contrat et donc avoir une
idée de comment on imagine et comment on
s'inscrit dans le temps sur ce
territoire et c'est là les programmes
qui interviennent par exemple sur la
ville centre ou sur avec PVD des
communes ou sur territoire industrie sur
une partie du territoire parce qu'on a
effectivement conjonction parfois des
des territoires et des zones
d'intervention ce contrat doit essayer
d'avoir cette dimension de
transversalité pour faire vivre
l'ensemble de ces dispositifs après on
peut comprendre aussi que ces programmes
qui correspondent à une politique
publique donnée correspondant à des
difficultés remontées du territoire et
partager par son d'acteur ont du sens un
s'il n'y avait pas eu je pense notamment
le programme type action coeur de ville
au territoire d'industrie avec des
acteurs dédiés et compétents sur ces
questions-là on aurait sans doute manqué
de levier pour réinvestir sur ces
territoires sur des questions qui sont
fondamentales qui sont les coeurs de
ville dans les villes moyennes et le
retour n'a rien industrialisation de
territoires qui sont périurbains au
bureau
sur la question du numérique et
l'inclusion numérique effectivement le
plan de relance a prévu des moyens
conséquents pas loin de 240 millions
d'euros de 150 millions d'euros sur des
10 sur sur le soutien et
l'accompagnement de la population vers
le numérique je l'évoquais d'ailleurs
comme un des sujets un monde à mon sens
clé pour l'avenir il y a différents
outils vous évoquez les en numérique
effectivement connaissent un déploiement
rapide très utile pour accompagner les
personnes les plus en difficulté pour
faire des démarches qui sont aujourd'hui
de plus en plus dématérialisées
la question de leur pérennisation
effectivement va se poser je peux pas
vous apporter une réponse aujourd'hui
mais évidemment c'est un point qui était
bien vu
parallèlement aussi les conseils
numériques que vous n'avez pas évoquer
ce sont déployés fortement on est à 3700
sur les 4000 qui sont déjà en activité
ou en formation qui sont très déployés
dans des collectivités dans des
associations et qui jouent un rôle alors
un peu moins d'accompagnement puissant
que les dents numériques qui fait à la
place 2 mais qui contribue aussi au
niveau de chaque collectivité
association concernées à accompagner les
populations les plus éloignées ou les
moins à l'aise avec le numérique vers
ces outils donc je crois que c'est un
très beau projet qui a vraiment très
bien marché qui marche très bien et qui
connaîtra j'en suis sûr un avenir
utile au-delà du plan de relance
monsieur le sénateur gilet sur la
question des évaluations je
[Musique]
vous rejoins dirons qu'il y a deux types
de
d'aspects sur les questions sur les
zones contradiles sur la gendarmerie
sur lequel nous travaillons une
évaluation est réellement menée d'abord
il y a eu des rapports parlementaires
qui sont faits il y a des rapports de
différentes commissions ou d'instance ou
d'inspection qui permettent de donner
des éléments d'analyse sur les
dispositifs c'est moins vrai sans doute
aujourd'hui sur un centre de programmes
encore récent qui ont été prévus ou
monter notamment depuis 2018 ou 2019
c'est encore très court néanmoins je
vous rejoins complètement il faut que le
dispositif d'évaluation soit intégré
systématiquement assez assez à ces
projets et assez programmes pour qu'on
puisse se poser la question au bout de
quelques années de leur fonctionnement
bon est-ce que ça a bien marché est-ce
que ça marchait la hauteur de ce qu'on
espérait ce qu'il faut réorienter une
partie est-ce qu'on arrête après tout la
question elle doit être posée aussi
parfois il faut peut-être mieux arrêter
que de poursuivre une je veux dire une
action qui n'a pas l'effet escompté
en revanche il faudra peut-être orienté
sur une nouvelle façon de travailler
donc je crois que cette question
d'évaluation elle est fondamentale et
sur Tous les programmes qui sont mis en
oeuvre aujourd'hui à NCT si je dois
rejoindre la direction générale j'y
serai très attentif sur la question du
guichet unique comment l'organiser vous
évoquez le fait qu'il y a
l'intercommunalité des départements mais
d'autres acteurs je les ai pas tous
cités tout à l'heure vous m'en excuserez
mais effectivement évidemment les Petr
qui sont des fédérations
d'intercommunalités ont un rôle clé
justement sur ces questions là notamment
de l'ingénierie c'est même le sens de
leur création je vous évoquais les
syndicats mistes bien sûr mais on a
aussi un des syndicats qui ont un rôle
en matière d'ingénierie très utile des
syndicats je pense à des grandes
syndicats départementaux autour des
questions notamment d'ingénierie de
voirie parfois d'électricité qui ont des
compétences opérationnelles très utiles
pour les petites communes et j'évoquais
aussi on a les parcs naturels régionaux
qui ont aussi disposent d'une ingénierie
voire des parcs nationaux qui peuvent
aussi porter un certain nombre de projet
donc on a tout un beaucoup d'acteurs sur
les territoires et même sur des
territoires bien pourvus c'est vrai que
parfois il faut travailler à la
coordination de l'ensemble et chacun
doit pouvoir trouver sa place mais il
faut effectivement avoir ce lieu
d'échanges et de dialogues pour éviter
ce sentiment qui a beaucoup d'acteurs et
en même temps qu'on trouve pas la
réponse à son problème donc ça c'est un
peu le rôle de ces comités locaux de
cohésion territoriale que de mettre tout
autour de la table et dire comment on
fait fonctionner en fonction des moyens
mis à disposition
le sénateur marchand vous évoquez la
question de des données
de la capacité à faire des photographies
des territoires vous le savez la NCT
dispose de deux observatoires
l'Observatoire de la politique de la
ville l'Observatoire des territoires qui
sont issus plutôt vous voulez
aménagement territoire l'autre plutôt
politique de la ville l'Observatoire des
territoires notamment produit
régulièrement des documents extrêmement
intéressants et riches par rapport à des
questions des thématiques qui concernent
et qui intéressent ces territoires
notamment par rapport au développement
économique de l'emploi ou des dynamiques
territoriales c'est les suites enfin
c'est aujourd'hui ce qui fut un temps
aussi ça s'appelait la data en termes de
projection de cartographie et avec des
outils cartographiques de très haut
niveau donc évidemment que ces
observateurs ont vocation et je les cité
exprès à alimenter les territoires c'est
pas uniquement une réflexion nationale
c'est le pouvoir le cas échéant sur des
thématiques avec le soutien des autres
acteurs compétents évidemment l'Insee
dispose de beaucoup de d'autres acteurs
vous évoquez l'alimentation au ministère
de la Culture je suis certain qu'on a
des données intéressantes mais la
capacité d'avoir ce regard et cette
capacité de production de documents
territorialisés en matière d'analyse des
de thématiques politiques publiques ces
observatoires en disposent et vous avez
raison il faut qu'on encourage et qu'on
déploie parce que souvent
avant de vous dire je veux faire tel
projet il faut se poser la question de
mais quelle est ma situation à l'instant
T et quelle est la dynamique dans lequel
je me trouve dans mon territoire au sens
large dans mon département dans ma
région
monsieur le sénateur Fernique vous
évoquez la question de la transition
écologique et
du fond vert alors comme je l'indiqué en
matière d'investissement mais je pense
que le ministre Béchu que je crois la
commission auditionnera cet après-midi
aura l'occasion de vous revenir plus en
détail que moi sur ce sujet
néanmoins évidemment le fond vert est
créé pour accompagner les territoires en
investissement principalement pour la
rénovation thermique la traitement des
friches la renaturation et accompagner
les territoires dans la transition
écologique mais un volet et je réponds
aussi à une des questions
à est dédié sera dédié aux questions
d'ingénierie il est prévu qui est une
part de ce fond vert qui puisse
accompagner la NTT évidemment sera
concernée par ce dispositif accompagner
les territoires à réfléchir sur des
thématiques de transition écologique sur
avec ses financements je précise quand
même qu'aujourd'hui plusieurs lots du
marché du grand marché d'ingénierie sur
mesure de la NCT prévoit déjà et peuvent
permettre d'accompagner des territoires
sur ces questions là donc c'est pas
quelque chose que la NCT découvrirait
elle a déjà et il y a une partie de ces
financements qui vont sur ce type de
projet notamment autour de les
rénovations thermiques et des
rénovations bâtimentaires dont on sait
que c'est un énorme enjeu compréhender
coûts pour les collectivités locales
sur la place du niveau régional j'en ai
pas suffisamment parlé un rapport de
l'igéa de 2021 évoqué le fait qu'il
fallait remettre dans le jeu le niveau
régional c'est sans doute nécessaire
j'allais dire il faut qu'on série les
enjeux mais le niveau des partants tel
est niveau d'appui le niveau de travail
au niveau de déploiement mais au niveau
régional d'un niveau effectivement de
coordination très important pour deux
raisons d'abord parce que il y a les
régions collectivités qui peuvent
évidemment de par leur compétences
d'aménagement territoire apporter un
soutien sur les projets territoriaux en
question que souvent des régions portent
aussi des disponibles d'ingénierie dans
lesquels ils doivent être coordonnés
avec ce porté au niveau local et que
effectivement au niveau régional vous
trouvez la plupart du temps le niveau de
représentation des grands opérateurs
ADEME cerema donc qui sont ou même
banque des territoires donc c'est un bon
niveau aussi d'échange j'allais dire
plutôt sur la stratégie régionale que
sur la déclinaison opérationnelle de
projet de territoire et de mise en
oeuvre d'ingénierie sur mesure mais
néanmoins fondamentale et c'est un enjeu
effectivement à remettre à remettre pour
les prochaines années
ce sénateur Dantec vous évoquez sur le
fond vert la question d'une partie
réservée à l'ingénierie je crois et
avoir répondu effectivement c'est le
sens des travaux que de la dgsl à
l'instant T nous nous auquel nous
participons apportés par le ministère de
la transition écologique et de la
cohésion des territoires qui est d'avoir
cette dimension réservée à une partie de
ses financements pour accompagner les
territoires dans cette transition
et l'enjeu il est effectivement au
niveau local en réinterrogeant sans
doute pour certains d'entre eux les CRPE
parce qu'on sait que certains ont été
faits ont été signés de façon assez
rapide que peut-être des enjeux n'ont
pas été complètement
identifiés et qu'il est intéressant de
les réinterroger pour faire valoir
toutes les questions de transition
écologique dans le projet qui a été
validé et l'accompagnement je reviens ce
que je disais à l'instant effectivement
de l'État et collectif peut passer
effectivement par le soutien de la NCT à
cette réinterrogation du CRPE contrat
intégrateur sur la question de la
rénovation thermique par exemple la
sobriété foncière qui est un élément
important avec la mise en œuvre d'usane
à moyen terme et de toutes ces
thématiques notamment de lutte contre
l'érosion de lutte contre aussi
l'artificialisation des terres
monsieur le sénateur Anglars sur alors
tout d'abord les commissariats de Macif
je les ai évoqués effectivement parce
que ce sont les bras armés d'une
politique notamment qui était le
programme avenir montagne qui est en
cours de déploiement qui est connaît un
vrai succès notamment avec une dimension
d'investissement une dimension
d'ingénierie et les commissariats de
massifs évidemment j'ai en tête même si
je suis pas en proximité immédiate mais
au moins quelques-uns qui ont contribué
largement à l'identification des sites
et bon déploiement de cette politique
donc leur rôle est vraiment très utile
et je considère qu'ils ont évidemment un
bel avenir devant eux au regard des
enjeux d'évolution d'un certain nombre
de territoires en montagne notamment sur
les évolutions en matière de tourisme de
forme de tourisme et d'évolution des
modèles économiques qui sont extrêmement
importants notamment pour la moyenne
montagne et qu'il faut accompagner ces
territoires dans cette transition de
leur modèle dynamique dont ils ont pris
conscience mais qui est quand même très
complexe et qui prend beaucoup de temps
et qui passe par un travail avec un
soutien typiquement apporté par les
commissariats de massifs
sur le fond vert je crois effectivement
avoir répondu sur le sur le contenu sur
la mise en œuvre le ministre beschu
pourra répondre évidemment aux questions
mais et il est clair que le sujet
aujourd'hui effectivement enfin il est
préconisé et proposé pardon que ce soit
un fond déconcentré donc mis en oeuvre
par les préfets mais le ministre pourra
mieux apporter que moi les réponses à
cette question tout à l'heure je pense
monsieur le président
je vais donner la parole à Louis Jean de
Nicolas
ah oui merci monsieur le Président je
souhaite pas intervenir puisque étant
membre du conseil d'administration de
l'anct je voulais pas être jugé partir
je laisse à mes collègues le soin de
choisir même si je voterai je voulais
juste te dire un mot d'ordre je remercie
tout l'ensemble des collègues des
interventions qui me permettront au
niveau du conseil d'administration de de
faire part de leur souhaits notamment
des éclaircissements de certaines
politiques je crois que monsieur le
directeur qui a un problème on le sent
de non transmission au niveau des des
comités locaux de cohésion territoriale
de l'action de la NCT et de la réflexion
avec les locaux sur les politiques
publiques mises en place par l'ancter on
le sent très nettement dans les
questions qui sont qui sont posées et je
le vois moi dans mon département le
comité local le cohésion territoriale
c'est simplement le préfet qui explique
ce qui a été fait sur le territoire
pendant une année mais il y a pas de
dialogue en fait sur les politiques
publiques qui pourraient être mises en
place ou l'explication des nouvelles
politiques public que mettre en place la
NCT
mais j'ai été ravi de travailler avec
vous
merci Monsieur sur ce sujet en fait je
pense que ça revient à la question de la
du format du guichet unique c'est toute
la question qui est à poser le guichet
unique c'est un peu un concept mais
comment on fait vivre concrètement c'est
à partir du besoin issu du territoire le
travail au niveau départemental il faut
qu'il y ait une porte d'entrée unique la
porte d'entrée c'est le délégué
territorial ses équipes déconcentrer de
l'État c'est le préfet mais le préfet
peut pas faire ça tout le temps
nécessairement est-ce qu'il faut
désigner un sous-préféré référent un DDT
un DDT adjoint référent clairement
identifié quel point d'entrée puis
ensuite un travail au niveau local de
coordination au sein du comité local qui
qui ne doit pas être simplement
l'explication ce qu'on a fait mais
effectivement un lieu de débat sur et de
fléchages et d'orientation avec le
soutien et un déploiement de moyens de
la NCT qui vient en appui notamment si
on voit qu'on est sur des projets
complexes qui ne trouvent pas de
solutions qui ne trouveront pas de
solution on regarde des moyens
disponibles au niveau départemental de
l'État comme des collectivités et puis
faire appel une fois qu'on a identifié
ce besoin par ce vecteur là via ce
guichet aux grands acteurs qui peuvent
être des acteurs publics
céréma ça peut être l'ADEME d'autres
mais qui peuvent être aussi un recours à
une prestataire un marché parce que ça
n'est pas forcément scandaleux ça peut
être très utile pour ce qu'on a un
besoin spécifique et ça peut permettre
de répondre à des besoins donc c'est
cette ce vecteur de concentration de
l'information de l'orientation qui doit
être retravaillée sans doute et c'est ce
que vous indiquez en disant qu'il y a ce
besoin encore de de
reposer et de refaire connaître et de
insister sur l'importance de ce point
d'entrée et de coordination d'interface
qui doit être au niveau départemental
puisqu'il n'y a plus de oui allez-y
allez-y allez-y Denise j'ai pas vu que
tu avais levé la main excuse-moi allez-y
oui monsieur Bouron je voudrais moi dire
que la NCT effectivement s'appuie sur
des services dans nos territoires
parfois même des services qui
appartiennent au département comme l'âge
des agences techniques départementales
les CAE mais qu'elle s'appuie sur des
services qui ces dernières années ont
été beaucoup et ça a été dit par mes
collègues beaucoup dépourvus de moyens
humains nuisant leur réactivité et à
leur efficacité dans l'accompagnement
des communes je pense ou des DT je pense
à Lana crédit de rénovation thermique je
pense au céréma l'Office national de la
biodiversité à l'ONF pensez-vous que
dans le programme pendant le projet de
loi de finances 2023 on peut espérer que
s'arrête cette hémorragie qui consiste
qui a consistait ces dernières années à
supprimer beaucoup d'emplois dans ces
services par ailleurs s'agissant des
maisons de service ce que nous entendons
beaucoup de la part des élus dans nos
territoires c'est que cette subvention
de 30000 euros cette aide financière de
30000 euros venant de l'État pour le
fonctionnement de ces maisons de France
service et véritablement insuffisance
pensez-vous qu'elle va être ou qu'elle
va être augmentée dans les dans les
années à venir et peut-être au PLF 2023
et pensez-vous surtout qu'elle va être
pérennisée
merci je vais dans la parole à décembre
parce que j'ai pas vu que tu avais
demandé la parole j'étais la première à
demander la parole président donc on va
gagner du temps parce que ma question ne
sera plus une question Monsieur le
Directeur général puisque mes collègues
et d'entrer le monsieur le rapporteur a
évoqué la question que je souhaitais
vous poser donc je ne vais pas vous
demander de réponse on va gagner du
temps
c'était je voulais évoquer ce qui a été
longuement évoqué le la porte d'entrée
unique pour l'ingénierie donc vous y
avez répondu très très longuement sur
son organisation sur sa durabilité
l'importance c'est qu'elle est qu'elle
continue à perdurer et vous avez même
rajouté une dimension qui est celle de
la coordination avec les autres services
etc donc vous y avez répondu je ne vous
demande pas de de
reformuler vos réponses par contre moi
je souhaite vous dire Monsieur le
Directeur général
je suis d'accord avec mes collègues
quand ils vous ont posé la question il
faut évaluer toutes les politiques qui
sont initiées sur les territoires c'est
vrai par contre lorsque vous serez
directement général de la NCT travailler
peut-être quand même sur un indice de
décrochage des petits territoires ruraux
parce que je pense pour ma part que
c'est pas la peine de dire il faut
encore des fonds supplémentaires etc il
faut élargir les territoires c'est pas
la peine d'aider ce qui n'anont pas
besoin c'est à dire ceux qui n'ont pas
réellement de difficultés par contre
pour les autres petits territoires moi
je suis très soucieuse ayez un indice de
décrochage pour être vigilant et tirer
la sonnette d'alarme quand vraiment des
territoires vont complètement décrocher
du système et c'est là que la NCT a
toute sa place je vous remercie
président
merci je vous laisse répondre à Madame
variateur merci monsieur le Président
alors sur les sujets du PNL 2023 et des
moyens alors qui dépassent le chant
quand même de champ d'intervention je
pourrais simplement vous dire ceci sur
les services en tout cas territoriaux
donc de l'État service des concentrés de
l'État il y a un engagement depuis au
moins deux ans en tout cas pour ceux que
je connais bien c'est à dire que tu es
mis à l'intérieur il n'y a plus de
baisse effectif voire il va y avoir
quelques renforts donc on est voilà la
réduction des effectifs dans les
services des concentrés d'amende dans
les préfectures préfectures et finit
depuis maintenant plusieurs années et
donc ce qui évite effectivement c'est
décrue qui peut poser effectivement des
problèmes après d’interlocuteur quand on
évoquait notre fonctionnement de notre
guichet unique
je peux pas répondre sur les grands sur
les autres je n'ai pas effectivement en
tête mais effectivement c'est un sujet
important parce que si on veut maintenir
aussi l'état en proximité et on a vu le
fait de réouvrir ou de
ou de renommer des sous-préfet dans
certains de sous-préfecture récemment
par le Président de la République il y a
ce souhait de réinvestir aussi la
proximité tous les territoires en
remettant aussi pas forcément beaucoup
de monde mais en tout cas des personnes
identifiées représentant l'État et
pouvant porter avec les collectivités le
discours un discours sur les territoires
sur la question de l'aide dans français
services il y a des débats effectivement
aujourd'hui sur le montant du soutien
vous savez que c'est un montant
aujourd'hui de 30000 euros alimentés par
le programme 112 pour 15000 euros et
15000 euros alimentés par une
contribution des ministères concernés ou
des structures ou les CRPM et autres
le débat sur le montant il sera
peut-être à avoir il aura lieu sans
doute dans les dans les dans les
prochains temps il faut avoir en tête
que l'État intervient aussi d'autres
façons il y a des soutiens
l'investissement des etr qui peuvent
être mis sur les Francs services il y a
le dispositif d'animation nationale
d'animation départementale de formation
qui est pris en compte et pris en charge
pour partie la question globalement des
moyens effectivement pourra se poser je
voilà aujourd'hui en tous les cas il est
sûr que ce soutien il sera à l'instant
de ce que je connais pérenne puisque en
fait le souhait c'est effectivement
c'est d'encourager le développement de
son service et poursuivre le maillage et
d'augmenter niveau de qualité encore et
de proximité donc on est dans un dans
une politique et ces mises Guérini avec
la ministre cailleux qui regarde ça de
très près on souhaite de continuer à
avancer donc voilà il y a une dynamique
positive donc pendant pas d'inquiétude à
avoir sur l'engagement de l'État sur ces
dispositifs puis pour la sénatrice
simple sur l'indice de décrochage des
petits territoires je trouve que c'est
très intéressant sur le thème le
décrochage on a des indices la DSL on a
plein de richesse de pauvreté de varier
mais on a aussi dans le travail sur les
ZRR des indices comme on dit composite
dans notre langage c'est à dire qu'on
prend le revenu on prend taux de
pauvreté etc mais cette question de la
variation d'un longtemps c'est pas
simplement la photo à l'instant T mais
comment il se dégrade ou quand on lui
s’améliore ce qui arrive quand même à
des endroits aussi et sans doute un
élément déterminant et je suis certain
que la NCT d'autres acteurs aujourd'hui
mais l'INSEE et autres peut travailler
sur ces questions pour mieux qualifier
les territoires ce que je disais c'est
avant de vouloir intervenir tout de
suite sur un projet à quoi est-on
confronté quelle est la dynamique du
territoire et peut-être à ce moment-là
voyons les moyens d'y répondre
voilà monsieur le Président merci j'ai
une demande de parole de Madame privile
merci monsieur le Président donc ma
question va être très rapide elle va
croiser celle de de ma collègue qui est
intervenue juste précédemment puisque le
but de la NCT c'était je pense de
réduire cette fracture territoriale avec
des territoires des collectivités qui
n'étaient pas en capacité d'avoir
l'ingénierie nécessaire pour pouvoir
évoluer de façon positive alors donc moi
je rejoins cet indice mais
quelle évaluation allez vous faire pour
ce qui a déjà été mis en place jusqu'à
présent et c'est vrai qu''évaluer les
projets c'est bien mais continuer très
concrètement à suivre les territoires
qui étaient en décrochage ce serait
absolument nécessaire puisque le but de
la NCT c'était justement de pallier à
ces à ces manques là donc comment
allez-vous les suivre très concrètement
merci je vous propose de répondre à ma
collègue merci monsieur le Président
alors là l'instant T je peux pas vous
apporter des réponses dans le détail
vous comprendrez je suis en je ne suis
pas encore dans les fonctions
sur l'évaluation je indiquais il y a des
dispositifs qui sont déjà soumis à
l'évaluation et pour lesquelles on aura
des données qui pourront être soumises
d'ailleurs au Parlement et au sénateur
lorsqu'on reviendra avec le cas échéant
un nouveau dispositif forcément je pense
notamment toutes les sujets autour de
des contrats de villes les questions
autour des zonages on a des éléments
d'évaluation d'ailleurs les rapports
sénatoriaux je pense sur les it erreurs
ont travaillé sur des éléments de bilan
sur par contre les programmes plus
récents je répète la NCT n'a pas trois
ans complète donc soyez plus récent pour
certains qui est daté d'un peu avant la
NTT je pense notamment à action cœur de
ville qui a démarré en 2018 19 donc on
est sur des effectivement une deuxième
étape on se voit bien qu'avec son cœur
de ville 2 est en train d'être lancé le
président de la République l'a annoncé
et il y a un travail qui est fait aussi
d'évaluation de ce qui de voilà ce qui a
déjà été accompli en trois quatre années
avec le coït au milieu ce qui reste à
faire donc il y a toute une dimension
dossier qui est d'évaluation qui est
mise en oeuvre mais peut-être qu'il est
faite son complètement toujours être
formalisé donc le souci si je devais
rejoindre la NCT ce serait sans doute
d'arriver à mieux formaliser ces temps
de d'évaluation institution dans un
délai cohérent parce que c'est pas au
bout de deux ans qu'on peut voir comment
on arrête une fracture territoriale
quand on sait le temps de déploiement
qu'il faut pour un une action de cette
nature et qui souvent donne des effets à
moyen ou long terme néanmoins savoir
déjà comme la dynamique c'est créer
comme on les outils ont été mis en place
comme les acteurs sont comparés ça peut
se faire au bout de quelques années et
donc c'est vraiment nécessaire qu'on est
ce temps d'évaluation régulière des
programmes nationaux mis en œuvre
bien merci s'il n'y a plus de monde de
parole je vais raccompagner monsieur
Bouron